UTTAM TRIPATHI: At
Google, we strive
to create great experiences
for our end users
through the products
and apps that we build.
In 2015, we found an
opportunity to do that
through a scalable program
working with developer agencies
globally.
JENNIFER KOHL: We work
with developer agencies
to give them access to
really interesting products
and features that
Google is working on
so that they can
incorporate them
into their applications
for their clients
and for their end users.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN:
We also trained
over a thousand developers on
various Google technologies
and were thus able to
improve the quality
of the overall
developer ecosystem.
Last year alone, we impacted
over 120 different apps
with a combined download
of over 100 million.
GUS GOSTYLA: We're very excited
about the Google Developers
Agency Program,
which helps us match
high-quality certified
agencies with startups and also
some very large brands that may
not have the skills in-house
to deliver on the app
that they dream about.
AMIT CHOPRA: We are now
able to identify and certify
agencies who have demonstrated
extreme competency in building
Android applications.
So whenever a customer
comes and asks us,
do you have a
partner who can build
a certain type of
application for me,
I have an excellent list
that I can offer to them.
PARUL SOI: These are
geoconsumer problems
that we are trying to
solve through this program.
The moment we increase the
skill set of the agencies,
if they really are dealing
with cutting-edge technologies,
they'd be able to solve
these problems in a much
better and productive way.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: The Google
Developers Agency Program
had such a great first year.
We were able to have a positive
impact both on the apps that
went to market,
as well as having
a positive impact through
feedback on Google's
own developer products.
JESSICA SCHWARTZ:
We have immensely
benefited from the
partnerships that we
have with various
developer agencies.
Right from the beginning,
we've partnered very closely
with a few teams to collect
feedback that has directly
impacted our product.
PARUL SOI: It is not very common
for developers, especially
in India, to have this kind
of exposure and training.
For instance, when we were doing
the TechGenie spotlight series,
one of the female
employees shared a story.
She was a senior
developer at a company
and had gone on
a maternity leave
just as they were becoming
our partner agency.
And when she came back
after close to a year,
the team she was leading
had actually learned a lot
from our program that she was
having to learn from them.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: I'm quite
proud with the expansion
of the program the
last couple of years,
with us working with agencies
across Europe, Americas,
and Asia and working with
a common goal of creating
the best quality
experience for end users.
AMIT CHOPRA: We are
definitely looking
at growing this into
many other regions
where we are
getting similar asks
from our partners
and our agencies
to build up this program.
DAVID MCLAUGHLIN: I can't
wait to see the impact
that this year will bring and
the improvements for hundreds
of millions of mobile
users all over the world.